which i
tried to um yeah practice pronouncing
his last name a bit better
and yes failed um
so yeah i don't know um studied at the
at central paris i'm in the computer
science and
a.i department and nowadays he's working
as elite data scientists
as which is a data consulting startup
specializing in computer vision
and he's going to talk with us um also
about
nfp but from different direction about
building nlp
pipelines to detect relationship between
fictional characters
so um yeah we are recording again
and i know the stage is yours
um and again everyone please ask your
question
in the chat whether you are in zoom or
watching us
in the youtube live stream
thank you for the introduction and thank
you for talking more
can everyone see the slides um yes it
looks good
okay um so i'm going to talk about
uh building an np pipeline for um
oh sorry i cannot see my remarks
uh oops so
i'm going to talk about being an ap
pipeline uh
she's going to be i would say a lot less
state-of-the-art
and a lot more on implementing
an np pipeline to do something you want
from nothing i would say so for
nlp expert some things may be well known
and maybe boring i'm excusing myself for
that
sorry so let's go
and i added some links and we already
talked about my
background so whoops sorry
basically right now i'm working uh at
which is
a computer vision firm and we do things
like optical character recognitions
detections a lot of things about
image search and stuff like that
so first what's the story of a project
i used to be a student at central paris
with uh all with this whole team of
eight people
uh we had like a stude stunt project
where we had to do something computer
science related
um to prove what we could do and
work together we were accident
and we had around two months we've
around eight hours a week to work on
this and currently i'm
sometime working on that project again
when i have some
spare time but i don't have much spare
time to do that
so what's the idea between behind the
project
we thought that would be fun uh
to use uh the unstructured data you can
find on the web so basically all the
websites
and use use them to
get behind the what is
a siri or any uh is
any story and make them into a graph
a relationship between the characters so
basically if you think about harry
potter you start with
a web page and what people wrote on
wikipedia and fandoms and other websites
and you try to find the fact that harry
potter is very admirable demo
is going out with jin usa
and he's friend with both airmen and one
with
uh and one wesley so that was we can
that was the world gist of it and that's
what we try to do
uh obviously with the time we had the
teacher just told us we had like
no chance to do that but as we were i
would say
young and foolish we tried
[Music]
and that's where it started
so to speak about the name there is this
whole tradition in computer science to
find
fun names uh about everything
so i'm taking the example of x stack
in data sense is the same we have yolo
tadam albert and other feminine names
so we cannot try to do our own things
and we named the project
swag which was stories with antagonist
graph
so yes we reach engineered the name and
uh
it was kind of silly but it's what it is
um
so what does the thing the wall thing
look like
uh so basically you start from a web
page where you can input
any story you think about so for example
a lot of rings harry potter
or whatever then we start scrapping the
page
so we scrap a bunch of page when we are
paying we applied a bunch of
uh nlp algorithms
and we do that with i would say life
status because
it's taking a bunch of time sometimes
around three or ten minutes and then
we give you the results so this is this
matrix of relationship where you can see
some ration between sarman and gandalf
and we'll see
we also have a graph view and
what is really funny is that sometimes
it makes appear people that you don't
even know about
so for example diego was the
i think the the friend and the cousin of
smirgo
and it only appears i think uh in a few
uh minutes of the movie and of the
serie basically they discover the wing
and uh smirgo killed diego so
that's the whole thing it's finding this
kind of relationship which is really
funny
so how does it work from an
architectural
standpoint we choose to go with
microservices
which is uh i would say now the
classical way to go
about it uh we split it in finding data
on the web
interacting with the user and turning
data into insights
and i have a blank page i don't know why
and so we are
around four or five services the first
one is the front that you can see the
same one is the back which is uh
basically implementing the wall socket
io thing to discuss with the front and
we have a scraping and an lp service
the front is using javascript
and connecting printing with a bag with
web sockets using socket io and
the scrapping part is made with go
language
uh basically because people love that at
the time
and wanted to do i would say fast uh
routine-like implementation of scrapping
and nap is made with python which is
i would say the standard at the time for
like doing everything that accentuated
and everything is communicating from a
message crew which is a nice way to do
that because
it's an easy way to scale the
application if you want to
deal with more user you just add another
container which is listening to the
message queue
so let's talk about an empty part i
won't talk
too much about scrapping
so first i you we used to go with an ltk
at the time which was
uh i think 2016. i don't think stacy was
that much of a thing at the time
honestly
now i'm trying to switch back to spacey
um i wanted to show a bunch of
uh reason to to choose a
heaver system tk
i took this graph from a medium post
honestly uh just if you think about
starting an mp pipeline
i use spacing at an ltk when you will
need an ltk you will know about it
basically it's like every time you want
to go further or find something that you
can do
with spacey or the rest of the time
species will be faster
easier to use and with a lot more
tools so
right now we're like in 2020
and i would have to apologize for not
using bert
so whatever reason we didn't use bert
first we didn't have money to train or
infer because
bad needs gpu and gpu cost money
the second reason is we didn't have
label data we didn't
have time to learn about bert or like
work and
iterate on the model and the last reason
was basically in 2016
a belt did not exist so that was
i think the first reason why we didn't
use birth
so joke apart uh the way we water in it
was
in a layered way we i'm going to go
through all those
layers and how we did it and
this is kind of a summary of it
so first thing is entry selection so at
that point you've scrapped a
load bunch of a bunch of web pages
and you want to know which page you have
to use
a funny thing about scrapping stories is
you have parodies
and others satire
pages or other stories so for example uh
this was a peak movie
and this is a kind of melting things
from harry potter's
over movies and i think uh
if you just read this page and use it it
will basically say something like
hypothetical dumbledore
which will not help you find the
relationship between harry potter and
doubler
so how we do that uh we want in
i would say a easy way so we basically
uh used some parody words and considered
the frequencies of both
in the web page if you have too much you
just
remove a page there is a lot of things
you can do with this kind of simple
word counting things such as
deciding whether your page is in french
or in english
and you can just come some things like
the stop words and remove
the french page i should have go with
german i guess
as we are like in berlin i'm supposed to
say but
uh here we are um so now
you have the page you want what you
should be doing with this
is removing all the um
i would say text characters that are not
relevant for processing so there are
things like uh uncles
up arrows and other things that you have
and you don't
want to have in your model
so the simple way to go with this
is using regular expression you find
some patterns and you remove them
it's kind of a pragmatic way to go about
it and
i think right now you may have other way
to do it with
more i would say advanced models but
kind of
you do that internally
so we used some regexes to remove
anchors that are related to other
articles or
put page notes
and here we are uh without the patients
i was going to speak about tokenization
but i think there's like a lot of
nlp people there uh the gist of it is
we basically went with an ltk at the
time
and now we're switching to spacing
which is a lot more effective
another issue is splitting sentences
this can be really hard
because when you use web page and you
didn't really
work with the way you want to use the
page
if you remove all the tags you may have
uh some uh
fake sentences which are footnotes and
uh
other comments coming from other parts
uh which can make uh the sentences in
art
so we had to add rules over what uh
most uh basically there is like
an ltk and
ntk and spacey could do
and now we have the sentences there and
clean
so what we want to do is find the
characters so the first thing is to use
an air
we used a specie which is quite
effective
at that and what we did is we retrained
it with some label data
it helpers go improve accuracy a lot
so to do that we use prodigy which is a
cool tool developed by explosion ai
which are also working on stacy
it's really easy to do and it helps a
lot
to win time
the last thing i would say in like
the sentence level processing is uh how
do you find relationship
so you have two characters and now you
want to know if they are related in any
kind of ration so
we kind of cheated on that so the way we
act around it is uh we thought that uh
initiation
is basically uh two characters and a
relation word
so we kind of created um a bunch
of uh relation words and we can
find way we find them in the sentences
uh using stems
once we have that we
we get the relationship
we match them with all the characters
you have in the sentence
and we scores all those so the way we
skip those is
uh adding um not a dependency pass thing
at all but we rather used um
distance based
score so we made a custom score
based on distance and using them we
scored every relationship for every
character's of every sentences
this is not optimal for a lot of reasons
the first thing is you're not semantic
at
all you have no
idea about negation so dalvador is not
looks favor won't work
duration can be a lot harder because for
example
you can say lily and james have a son
and then if you use sun as a keyword
we think that lee and james have a
parent-child relationship which is not
the case at all
uh so why does it work uh the first
reason why it
does work is uh you have a lot of um
relationship sentences thanks to a good
named entity recognition algorithm and
the second way
of the second reason why is with a lot
of
weak ration detection on a lot of
example
it kind of adds up to a good performance
so at that point you have all the
sentences
you add them and you do a weighted sum
and all the corpus so basically
something like
uh a thousand pages
and once you're done you add some
threshold and uh with the thresholding
you
predict the relationship between the
characters the last thing you have to
add
is um character aggregation because
in a corpus you have a lot of way to
relate to single characters
so for example you can say voldemort's
also
also known as you know who so you can
pass those kind of sentences to make a
relation between the characters and
know that voldemort and who know who is
the same person
and the other way to do that is using
name clustering
so for example if you only have harry
and harry potter
you may guess that aryan harry potters
are the same person
which is not always the case because
because you can have james potter
so we have we basically used i would say
a character level and
uh world level levenshtein distance
and we added some other tricks
uh to uh do this name clustering
so once you get that uh i would say you
have everything to make it work
or cannot work and this is what we
presented
to the teachers of the time uh
to go further there is a lot of reason
why this task is really hard
uh one of the first one is the
chronology of stories
uh basically your stories is about uh
evolution of characters
with a plot and uh you can have
a relationship that evolves a lot so for
example rogue one from the bad guy
to the hero at the end of the story and
so
at what point he's the enemy and the
friend of harry potter is not easy to
say
the same thing is uh what is the meaning
of relationship uh it made difference a
lot
uh between the stories so for example
in some stories you can have people
fighting because
that's basically what they do that's
like their studies or their work or
whatever
so they maybe start fighting for fun and
not the enemy at
all so what makes relationships
sometimes hard to define mainly between
friendly and
um i would say enemy relationship
the third thing which is hard is correct
and
uh it's happens a lot in sentences so
it's basically saying it's harry potter
and then saying something like he he's
the brother or he's the son of james
potter
and if you do that basically right now
algorithm won't be able to do anything
about it
and we also talked about
semantic which is the previous example
and entity linking which is sometimes a
really hard task because
some characters may be related in a lot
of different ways
to themselves the last issue we had
which is maybe the most important one is
knowing how good we are basically
uh as limer said before some tasks are
we are
to kind of evaluate and in a case
we didn't really have a corpus at all to
know
what what the what whatever relationship
between all the characters
um and and so that's a hard way
um that we are to iterate uh if we don't
know
if we're improving or
basically making vargo even worse
so one other thing i'm working on right
now is
kind of labeling all this
which is taking time i try to use
dbpedia
for the one who knows it's a
i would say through to a structured
database based on the wikipedia
data it's not really able for
a relationship basically so we kind of
have to work on that
[Music]
the other thing we tried and i'm
currently working on
is labeling data at the sentence level
and it's really hard because uh there is
no really good way to
label a relationship which is open in an
open source way
um the way project is going about it
is um encourage you to
use uh dependency passing uh
the dependency passing ui and make a
proposal
the other issue with this is uh in the
corpus of around
1000 web pages you have a lot of
sentences that are useless
and that you don't want to label at all
and so
you will lose a lot of time so you have
to find a way to filters
how the sentences that are not relevant
in any way
so the last thing i'm currently working
on and which is related to the previous
one
is improving the way we detect
relationship
and the first and easiest way to do it
when you don't have level data
is to use dependency parsing so
i'm currently working on creating a
bunch of rules to detect
and improve the relationship detection
this is hard because it takes a lot of
time to find all the way
around and to find examples that are
present in the corpus
the cool way is that you can afterward
use that to validate and
label your data so i think it's
uh kind of everything
about the subject i wanted to show a
bunch of examples
and what it looks like at the end so
um on a lot of i would say stories you
have
a lot too many people that are involved
you cannot see what's happening if you
zoom in
you can see things like this where you
can see that
dumbbell doors and harry potters are
related in a mentorship
way because dumbledore is kind of a
teacher
for harry potter you can see that ron
and
um and harry are friends
and you can see for example things like
harry potter and jimmy
are lovers as they are at the end of the
story
they used to be friends or are they are
still and there used to be enemy
uh mainly i think in the second volume
uh
in the chambers of korea where um
i think ginny succumbed to the influence
of voldemort
so i would say if you kind of look at it
this way
it worked quite well uh
i still have to assess with a real
metric and
find what's a score for that
only if i'm still showing and i can
switch to another page
am i yes
so it looks something like that and you
can like
basically find the relationship between
every characters
uh so for example we will be with and
fleur de la cru
and you have um the graph you which is
a buggy right now and
i won't make a full presentation of how
you can
run it because it takes a lot of time
but the idea at the time was to
kind of show off during the uh end of
um presentation by making it run
but it times it takes around 10 minutes
so you can do something like
typing uh a lot of the rings
or anything and it will start just
scrapping
so here i go i'm done do you have any
question
okay thank you very much renault um if
anyone has questions please
post it in the chat whether you're in
the zoom call
um or on youtube on youtube
um
yes so um i don't know maybe you can
um present what other
applications this approach has so
you showed us here for kind of a book
but do you intend to do it maybe
on um can you do it maybe for wikipedia
to extract
entities from wikipedia articles or news
segments
yes so basically as it's starting from
a wiki page or a fandom or anything
i used to uh try to start
on like non-people like politician and
you can like
ask for i don't know barack obama or
donald trump
or joe biden or whoever and he will like
find the pages
and kind of work i would say which is
maybe a bit scary i guess
yeah a graph about the world leader
[Music]
one of the cool thing would be to i hope
i can do this one day but
i cannot use that to create this
structure that i use by wikidata
and kind of share what i kind of steal
to them which is all the work they did
uh to like make all those pages it would
be a fun and i would say to this project
if i uh i'm able to do something uh good
enough
um could you share also um the link to
the github purpose the
project um i cannot swear now
no okay so it's not on github yet okay
no i could share the link to the
website uh if some people try but the
issue with that is
uh it takes a lot of computation it's
running on some
uh servers and if you do that we'll be
spammed
uh okay yeah and so we won't be able to
do anything else
because it's able to handle something
like two or three users
at a time and uh even one is like around
like five or ten minutes
so to become kind of harsh for the
servers
uh we have a question in the sense in
the chat if you tried
um that any temporal elements
and like in your example to kind of
follow relationship between characters
over time or for example over the books
that's a really good question i wish i
could do that
right now i have kind of no idea how to
do this basically because
i don't even know which pages go in
which orders
sometimes you end up on uh summaries and
so
summaries is really cool because you can
have like a basic relationship between
people but it doesn't necessarily follow
the story
uh some other things are fun stories or
kind of uh
hypothetical things that could happen in
the rest of the story
and so all of that doesn't make it
really easy to
guess based on i would say the page or
any kind of chronological event
what's happening before and what's
happening after
so in a way you're presenting now kind
of an average of the relationship over
time in case there is some development
or change
yes uh one other thing i want to work is
basically
i want to work on is things like i would
say
brotherhood relationship should not
evolve that much unless you're in game
of thrones
so some relationship could be kind of
splitted apart from the rest of the
of the other relationship so i could
be in this situation for enemy versus
friendly
but kind of have like a direct answer
for the other one to be i would
guess cooler cooler
okay thank you very much
we maybe can finish the recording
and also say goodbye to all of our
viewers on youtube